someone decided to break the Guinness
record Guinness world record for most
expensive pet wedding ever that's right
it's it was a marriage between two dogs
and it was a giant Catered Affair and it
even featured a wedding cake made by the
Cake Boss okay and this was you know
people were talking about was in the
news they were trying to break a world's
record now here's the best part this is
the reason I'm bringing this up one of
our very dear friends attended this
historic pet wedding
and we have a clip from the event ladies
and gentlemen take a look
when my reputation is on the line I will
join
do infect
and you know what this event was perfect
this wedding was the most expensive pet
wedding in history we got the number one
lighting person the number one flower
person we got the most amazing wedding
platter and it's truly been seriously
like a fairy tale I was very worried
about the rabbi the only thing I said to
him is please please don't make this
classless
shiny
[Applause]
[Music]
baby hope
cheating
all of us are delighted to share your
joy with you on your wedding day
we're also delighted that we've gone 10
minutes up here and no one has taken a
piss on the floor
as we all know a dog wedding is very
different from a human wedding
with humans the husband Waits until
after the marriage to have his balls cut
off
of course this is a Jewish wedding so
when they took baby hope to get her
fixed she said start with the nose
[Music]
[Applause]
but fortunately chili you can still lick
yourself down there which is something
you'll need when you marry a Jewish girl
[Music]
this is a sacred occasion
tonight we are setting a new Guinness
world record for most expensive dog
wedding
it also set the record for most
expensive animal wedding not involving a
Kardashian
[Applause]
[Music]
and offer you these words
I know that neither of you have any idea
what I'm saying
I know that if these two dogs
were able to talk tonight they would
look around this room
at all that's been arranged and all
that's been done for them
and say this is [ __ ] insane
seriously we're dogs
I kid okay let's do this I Now Pronounce
You dog and [ __ ]
you may sniff the bride stush
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]